okay the technical difficulties we're
playing citation needed joining me today
he reads books you know it's Chris Joel
hello I'm Chris Jill Christ College
Oxford reading references to surfing in
the early King James Bible everybody's
favorite David Brown and Gary Brannan
so the hooker with a sickly smile shook
hands with a monkey could never look
banana in her face again and the
Bounty's man on the internet my gray
hello live studio audience in front of
me over the house open Wikipedia and
these folks can't see it every fight we
get right to the point and a ding and a
special prize for particular good
answers which is yeah and today we are
talking about Jack
Churchill it's just a method by which
wouldn't raise a wartime Prime Minister
I mean I'm glad that's the version the
verb you went with I'll be only a bit of
a coin I really love it such has been
raised Everson I yes
you may check my undercarriage for where
yeah no nobody needs to see more
authoritative he's a lot shorter than we
shall fight them on the beaches in the
Strait idea but but Churchill is now
just suck about six-foot about everyone
else's chair you can't possibly get down
from I wish I think Beasley noise in
Starling comes in on a cherry picker it
explicitly says at the end of this
article of no relation to Winston
Churchill
well five minutes he's got enough to try
to fight World War two with a climber
no no no you said sold over there is a
heck of a lot more to this story going
on a claymore is a proximity triggered
no no no hand and a half Scottish saw
how sword yeah oh yeah Barrymore is in
mine as well but yeah yeah this is okay
different type of claim oh yeah okay has
been Scottish Klansmen OH
unless he off the entire continent and
that was basically his remit wow that
was why he went into the war to do Wow
why do you think he was born not
Scotland not Scotland up but runs on
sale on ok Shanker uh actually you say
drafted he joined oh yeah I was on
record in in the 1920s oh well only
because there weren't enough things to
cut off in salami well yes he left the
army in 1936 because there was not
enough fighting well he can so he then
worked as as a few other things what
what might that be one one is is a
phrase I wouldn't associate with the
1930s of a job for a strapping young lad
sadly technician okay sir operative of a
mildly successful nail bar a little bit
off the top right whoa male model
clearly that he also uses archery and
bagpipe talents oh boy a role in a film
called The Thief of Bagdad with bagpipes
with a bagpipe the fact that without a
thief of bagpipes he won second place in
the military piping competition at
Aldershot tattoo without Eliza cake
would some bags like oh I bet sit to tie
mr. Gilardi well he also represented
Britain of the world archery
championships so we also use the
backlight no this this was this is a
longbow godly would be Second World War
breaks out and he decides not to bring
the longbow
cause in practical or wrong really
really both and I hope I've got one of
these
Fiorina was going too far back it was
$13.99 with the Manchester regiment are
in France and ambushed a German patrol
how did he give the signal to attack did
you just scream and run not this time
I'll give you the point because yes he
did that sides of a time he was in
command of the troops how'd he give the
signal to attack did he have his
bagpipes with him haha - yeah with the
drone Vinny does not this skill that's
not not really used here flaming arrow
slamming at it I'm gonna give you the
point he he killed nanyem sergeant with
the longbow oh boy that was it that he
was the ollidy arrow with the bow the
yet with the stringy bits the unholy
fire the tentacles of the stringy bit of
effort yeah the last recorded person
ever killed during war time with a long
bow and arrow whoa yeah I'm sergeant now
I've just noticed something
yes this man seems to have a punch on is
that the word for running into battle
and screaming yes he managed to go into
several battles many battles without
dying
yes yeah with the longbow you are quite
a way back Norway 1941 landing craft on
a raid on a German garrison
yeah I'd paint me a picture what I'm
thinking
nighttime yeah I imagine not now you
think it's a point of when he starts
playing the bagpipes what is that coming
from other the ocean
yeah that's worried worst action in the
world without me the bellowing part of
Norway who states the German garrison
out of Francis like yeah would you do it
over the ocean or would you enter the
landing craft had silently approached
the B through the wisp of the wind
through the trees as the Clank of the
metal teeth of instantly her you're
nearly right yes he looked forward from
his position playing on his bagpipes
before throwing a grenade and running
into battle this money are you gonna do
anything just to start just to be inside
his head of the approached the beach
playing that with the backpack ready to
go the grenade
peed in his hand thinking yeah we're
going to do this this is my son yes if
that was me I pulled the pin drop the
bagpipe and you know just be a loud
party explosion they say he threw a
grenade did it hit anything I do know is
by not saying it's not recorded here I
don't know why era so we've had front
1940 Norway 1941 where was he in 1943
Italy correct
was it lies good am i doesn't it not
sure not a couple miles on the road on
the army slide I've seen a video of a
bagpiper Takashi it was even I'm going
to drink that later
go on it was in the 70 the news the best
is the one show of the seventies
nationwide did the same I don't know why
because I've only seen the clip itself
it's a bagpiper a low altitude plane
it's got the parachute on one of those
called the earth nothing think of it
yeah jumps out starts playing Scotland
the brave on the way down and it's great
because he gets in he gets the drowning
man in and it hits the ground and he
cannot do a London and hold on Sebago I
saw saying I got to pull you got a flag
you've got to pull down both straps and
that's a Technical Centre so--but the
wall I heard was man and he got dragged
along by the wind on the for the
mournful part of the bag yeah this sadly
was not a parachute this was this was a
landing site was this again the same as
Norway yet slightly sunnier this is the
things Norway yet slightly more Oh what
hasn't he used whoa he was Lupo as well
yes he had the he had the broadsword the
longbow and the bagpipes and the grenade
it doesn't say doesn't say he's like the
things the people you get in computer
games but it's funny because you could
never carry all these how's he carrying
all of these did you get that problem I
give it a Olding a subordinate yes I'm
playing the back post we should dig into
two-handed sure how fantastic woulda be
see just had a Batman ma are you going
going back like another 50 years where
you just have a gentleman the gentleman
with you just taking on the battle
broadsword
ah she's a little way off longbow you
know nothing's happening backpacks will
sign some more number 3 wood for the
green just a teaching wish they're all
fully dug in I was thinking more cricket
bat I'll think I was thinking picture up
[ __ ] yeah
thankful Zambian - I think I think we
call someone saying that the effective
range of a grenade is further than you
can throw it right so you do need
something like a bat behind it then what
all you need to tuck it into somewhere
and move move out we give you you're
choking it I'm running away I thought
the backside bats occur in a hey ya
reckon I would oh wait no we're second
on the detonator just for risk for the
pitch up if you miss it you're in
trouble look at it so this wasn't one
for the courageous soldier did after he
infiltrated the town yeah we're in the
right fights hang on not they he
infiltration and this man don't sound
like words they rode together seems he
was ordered to capture a German
observation post how did that go uh
surprisingly well no I'll give you the
point he captured 32 prisoners no one
tried to shoot the bagpipes I mean I'll
be honest it's not the first thing you
well I don't know if you say depends how
empty bagpipe you are living I was there
that would be the first thing I'd go for
you've got three bullets what do you
shoot the bagpipes three times I could
just see the bullet going through hood
shut my pipes no I'm angry and he wasn't
Scottish I'm the pointer he was Scottish
yeah well they wouldn't know that he was
captured yes what was a do you know the
story there are I can only presume that
he was captured went along willingly
beat all the guards at chess and poker
drank drank the camp commandant rum then
dug his way out with his teeth while the
commandant was passed out chewing on
broken glass and spitting it a guard
before having relations with the entire
female population of the nearest town
lighting a cigarette on the ground not
even using a match flipping the vmn
walking into the camp and saying one of
you
do it Tom just as a gasps Tom please dig
below me not even close for a minute I
crawled under the wire through an
abandoned drain and tried to walk to the
Baltic coast end up being recaptured
escaped again walked 93 miles to Verona
in Italy and met the Americans there I
bet they were delighted to see him uh
and then continued and went to Burma
arriving in 1957 well this thing by the
time you got there what happened was a
war over yes absolutely right um that
must have been very disappointed for him
I'm gonna quote here if it wasn't for
those damned Yanks we could have kept
the war going another 10 years see what
you did you ruin that man's 19 why that
isn't insight into his mind isn't it yes
I really did without his own question
what defect any deal after the war
because he is tilled up and angry well
he wore him on a check out in size oh no
walk back from Burma to career they want
to Vietnam to the answers I'm giving you
a retroactive point here
Oh respected funny because you've
already said the word what did he
qualify as in the army supermarket your
narrow professional supermarket sir
where did that come from he said he
might every supermarket and that's all I
was there that brain sector will do it
Supermarket become a long day that's bad
take away anywhere fully muffled aligned
how Wonderlic kills that he's not
wearing yeah yes
nail bar parachutist ah there are
stories him assisting a medical convoy
coordinating evacuations also things
like that and then coming back to
England went back and make another
appearance in the film was he in a Bond
film no he was in Ivanhoe was he what he
appears
a bagpiper close a longbowman yes
absolutely yeah
what skill did he take up in late 1950s
Australia boomerang wagging no no no no
I mean being very specific word but I
think that that action
I could nobody claims boomer wagging
and also no Wang is under armed isn't it
I didn't Wally Wang Ying ah a patient of
the wearing their every phrase Wally
Wang Ying was just lost on half field
gumboot throwing him you are from the
Home Counties yeah doesn't have to work
well II know no what's a Wellington
isn't it as in after dwellings it's over
but it also brings about the nines the
excellent name 1980s computer company
from Oxfordshire wearing and that Oxford
United in the nineteen eighties were
sponsored by four years with the word
Wang repeatedly late nineteen fifties
Australia what was being developed there
surfing yes absolutely right
yeah he became a passionate I'm quoting
here passionate devotee of the surfboard
one of the first people in Britain to
surf and specifically one of the first
people in Britain to surf what seven
ball point you're absolutely right the
river thing by the way I will say yeah
there's a single tidal wave that on
particularly strong tides rolls up the
river seven and nowadays like it's
filled with surfers boats and drones
flying overhead just this guy on a
surfboard
one pissed-off guy from so long playing
the bagpipes showing they claim our own
event having finally conquered another
element opening your hair Simpson yeah
can you hear bagpipe I can buy this
Placid River salmon with the occasional
oh sweet job ah
the end of declare Warren himself uh in
retirement it says he didn't retire his
eccentricity continued no settle down
you know people in the Hitler retirement
Aug so plus I've seen last of the summer
what are you doing last of the summer
wine on the revival bathtub he startled
train conductors we passes following his
briefcase out of the train window each
day on the ride home why did he try and
get in one of the post office next for
the post offices the what the way they
used to pick up mail in ye old and
you've got yelled and they know that in
the days of traveling post offices you
would have a hook by the side of the
railway line they were dangled a bag
full of mail at which point the carriage
would come towards it had a bit of
sticky out net that would be dropped out
in exactly the right moment would hit
the hook the mail bag would drop into
the net and be sprung into the carriage
which time another book would be slung
out from the Train with another bag of
mail that would be dropped in the same
location like that Wow precise timing
and speed and location in such a way
that they don't have to stop to pick up
the mail exactly it'll go trigers do
criminal and then the post has happened
the letters be it is literally like mail
crossing the bottom and suddenly back on
in this case briefcase ascending claimer
and primary mummy didn't on it he wasn't
trying it on the mail pole well he was
aiming for a specific target in garden
ah that is amazing I want to do that on
the way home doesn't quite work in the
tomb I was really sick when he moved to
London let the age of 90 look at the
prior gorillas just walked away
he died in 1996 and was later named one
of the finest explorers and adventurers
of all time
by himself by the Royal Norwegian
explorer at the end of the show out
congratulations Chris you obviously win
this one either inside the Madeleine
with the yeah there's a regular I really
congratulations you win two words mixed
together by the actor who played Padme
in the Star Wars prequels no it's a
Natalie Portman tell with that we say
thank you to Chris Joel Hagel Gary
Brannen tonight right I can come Scott
we'll see you next time
you
[Applause]